et avec nous le politologue Bruno
cotress bonjour Bruno merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous et Frédéric David nous
a rejoint bonjour Frédéric directeur
général opinion de l'Ifop Steve est avec
nous re bonjour Steve on va parler des
consultations à Matignon très Isabelle
Bornel et syndicats qui ne veulent pas
tourner la page de la réforme des
retraites empêcher l'examen de la
proposition de loi pour abroger la
réforme des retraites seraient
inacceptable prévient Laurent Berger
alors que la majorité présidentielle
veut brandir un article de la
Constitution pour rendre ce texte il
recevable et puis on parlera du Sénat
qui a lancé ses travaux sur le fond
Marianne se font lancer après la mort de
Samuel Patier dont l'attribution est
controversée alors y a-t-il scandale
d'État on verra les temps forts des
premières auditions si vous avez suivi
ça hier avec attention d'abord en
regardant ensemble l'actualité dans nos
régions
et dans nos régions avec nos partenaires
de la presse régionale on va à Poitiers
retrouver Baptiste bise directeur
adjoint de la Nouvelle République et
Centre Presse dans la Vienne bonjour
Baptiste merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
on va parler avec vous de Joël robucheux
près de 5 ans après la mort de Joël
Robuchon vous allez nous parler ce matin
du projet d'institut gastronomique qu'il
souhaitait créer dans le Poitou
ouais nous ont effectivement le point
dans les éditions de la Vienne de la
Nouvelle République et de centre presse
ce matin sur le projet d'institut
gastronomique Joël Robuchon dans les
derniers mois de sa vie le chef le plus
étoilé du monde avait jeté toutes ses
forces dans ce projet qui lui tenait
très à coeur pour comprendre ce projet
il faut savoir que Joël Robuchon était
né et avait grandi à Poitiers dans le
quartier de la cathédrale il en parlait
toujours avec beaucoup d'émotions et il
restait très attaché à son Quatu il
avait racheté la maison construite par
son père de ses propres mains et tenait
absolument à laisser ce centre de
formation d'excellence en héritage au
poids de vin alors près de 5 ans après
son décès cette institut n'a toujours
pas vu le jour mais le projet avance au
départ l'idée était de créer un institut
gastronomique dans le cadre magnifique
de la Maison Dieu de Montmorillon au sud
de Poitiers depuis le chef est donc
décédé la crise du covid est passée par
là et une partie du projet a été
réorientée à Chasseneuil-du-Poitou comme
une connue pour avoir été le fief de
l'ancien Premier ministre Jean-Pierre
Raffarin mais aussi pour son Futuroscope
le 15 décembre dernier le Conseil
Régional de nouvelle Aquitaine a
approuvé la création d'une école
régionale de la restauration collective
pour un investissement de 30 millions
d'euros sur le site d'un ancien lycée de
cette commune de l'agglomération de
Poitiers et le site qui s'intègre au
projet Robuchon accueillera des
apprenants qui viendront suivre des
formations vers l'excellence en
restauration collective plus récemment
il y a un mois un permis était délivré
pour un autre bâtiment pour la
construction d'une école de formation
culinaire de type lycée hôtelier destiné
à accueillir 200 étudiants dans une
vingtaine de formations sur la
technopôle du Futuroscope sur les
plantes que nous avons pu consulter les
visages de Joël Robuchon et de sa fille
Sophie apparaissent en grand format sur
la longue façade vitrée du bâtiment sur
ce site de trois hectares un restaurant
serait créé sous le nom de Sophie
Robuchon
Baptiste le chef étoilé de Haute-Loire
Régis Marcon fait aussi partie de
l'aventure
à ce jour le tour de table financier
n'est pas bouclé pour l'école de
formation culinaire sur le site du
Futuroscope et les investisseurs ne se
sont pas encore formellement engagés
pour le projet de Montmorillon de son
côté le président délégué du département
en charge des grands projets espèrent
toujours une ouverture de
l'établissement de Régis Marcon des
septembre 2026 merci beaucoup merci
c'est d'avoir été
la Nouvelle République où en est le
projet d'institut Robuchon c'est à la
haine de votre journal ce matin merci
Baptiste bise d'avoir été avec nous pour
nous parler de cette actualité on va
parler de l'actualité du Sénat
maintenant estime c'était hier le top
départ de la commission d'enquête du
Sénat sur le fond Marianne oui une
commission d'enquête mise en place à
l'initiative du groupe socialiste et qui
vise à répondre à une question comment
des fonds publics ont été distribués par
le gouvernement dans sa lutte contre le
séparatisme on parle en l'occurrence de
l'argent du fond Marianne une structure
lancée en avril 2021 par mail Marlène
Schiappa alors ministre chargé de la
citoyenneté on est dans la foulée de
l'assassinat de Samuel Paty et le
gouvernement souhaite financer des
projets pour diffuser les valeurs de la
République 2 millions et demi d'euros
sont débloqués pour l'occasion et des
millions qui ont été gaspillés c'est la
question oui qui se pose en filigrane 71
associations déposé des projets 17 ont
été retenus parmi ces 17-2 ont capté la
majorité des financements les sénateurs
veulent donc savoir sur quels critères
ces associations ont été sélectionnées
ils ont donc auditionné hier le préfet
Christian gravelle il est secrétaire
général du comité interministériel de
prévention de la délinquance et de la
radicalisation c'est
ipdr c'est ce comité qui était chargé de
la gestion administrative des fonds
alors sur quels critères l'argent est-il
a-t-il été débloqué hier on n'a pas
vraiment une réponse écoutez-le dans le
cas particulier de ce comité de
sélection étant donné l'enjeu je concède
pleinement que nous aurions dû
collectivement envisager un compte-rendu
avec également un certain nombre de
Verbatim en tout cas au moins saisir
saisir la logique qui permettait
d'expliquer pourquoi tel ou telle
association a été choisie ou telle autre
ne l'a pas été les choix ont été faits
ont été mesurés et pesés
et il était plus précisément question
Steve hier de deux associations oui ces
deux associations qui ont capté la
majorité des fonds il faut entrer dans
le détail de cette affaire qui a été
révélée à l'origine par nos confrères de
Marianne et de France 2 On parle de
l'association reconstruire le commun qui
a touché 330
000 euros à la publier plusieurs vidéos
critiques sur des candidats de gauche
notamment pendant la campagne électorale
la deuxième association c'est l'US ppm
l'Union des sociétés d'éducation
physique et de préparation militaire
elle a obtenu
355000 euros pour des publications en
ligne très peu suivies sur internet et
les réseaux sociaux
mediapart révèle ce lundi que les
candidatures de ces deux associations
reposées sur des dossiers très fragiles
le dossier du US ppm ne comportait par
exemple qu'un simple document A4 réponse
de Christian Gravel hier
j'ai compris avant de venir vous voir il
y a quelques jours que vous n'avez pas
reçu quelques pièces et notamment les
fiches d'instruction exhaustives de
certains projets donc cette
recette que vous nous avez envoyé voilà
c'est bien pour ça que je vous dis c'est
une erreur de notre part nous aurions dû
vous envoyer cette pièce je pense
notamment à l'uspm qu'on va sans doute
évoquer dans quelques instants et il n'y
avait pas je vous rassure d'emblée
qu'une fiche d'une petite page nous
avons reçu une fiche d'instruction en
bonnet due forme de plusieurs pages qui
étaient très détaillées et qui
permettait évidemment d'étayer et de ce
qui a été notre cas de nous convaincre
d'envisager du lieu accorder la première
subvention pour les sénateurs n'ont pas
vraiment été convaincus par cette
audition les documents dont parle le
préfet vont maintenant être transmis au
sénateur à faire à suivre la prochaine
audition de la commission d'enquête
c'est la semaine prochaine et on suivra
évidemment tout ça c'était un peu fou
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire si vous
avez suivi ça avec attention hier Bruno
kotresse est-ce que ça entretient le
fait qu'il y a eu un problème avec ce
fond Marianne
toujours effectivement qu'on ne puisse
pas dire très rapidement très clairement
qu'est-ce qui a conduit au choix d'un
projet normalement
l'état d'esprit du code des marchés
publics en tout cas voilà et de
l'utilisation de l'argent public c'est
qu'on recherche toujours l'équilibre
entre le mieux disant sur le fond du
dossier il me disant budgétaire le me
disant budgétaire ne peut jamais servir
de d'arguments
ultime puisque c'est pas parce que une
proposition est pas chère entre
guillemets ou elle a un budget faible
qu'elle est forcément choisie il faut
encore qu'elle réponde bien sur le fond
donc normalement on doit assez pouvoir
rapidement présenter un argumentaire qui
motive le choix d'un d'un dossier
lorsque quelqu'un candidate à un fond
public et sur ces deux aspects donc
normalement ça devrait être relativement
simple il y a un cahier des charges
normalement ce cahier des charges fait
l'objet l'examen dans une commission et
cette commission doit être normalement
extrêmement attentive au compte-rendu
qu'elle doit faire parce que il peut y
avoir aussi des personnes qui n'ont pas
été sélectionnées qui demandent des
comptes donc voilà il faut assez
rapidement que ceux qui ont participé au
dispositif de sélection puisse répondre
sur ces deux questions le fond et le
budget qu'est-ce qui les a amenés à
conduire et puis un question aussi qui
est l'utilisation c'est à dire qu'est-ce
qui a été fait là ça fait deux ans que
ce fond a été créés donc du point de vue
on va dire du fonctionnement des
institutions il est bon que les
assemblées ou que un moment donné celui
qui veille à la bonne utilisation des
fonds publics puissent au bout de deux
ans demander des comptes qu'est-ce qui a
été fait quelle est la valeur ajoutée et
ce sont des questions qui sont
essentielles parce que vous savez le
l'opinion est très sensible à ces
questions il y a un climat de l'opinion
qui considère que le politique s'exonère
très souvent des des demandes qu'il
adresse à la société il a une demande
d'exemplarité par rapport à la société
et beaucoup de Françaises et Français
considèrent que le politique rapidement
s'exonère un peu de de cette de cette
perspective et on va demander à Frédéric
est-ce que cette affaire du fond
Marianne prend dans l'opinion est-ce que
c'est un impact absolument pas pour
l'instant chaque semaine nous posons des
questions d'actualité ouverte on sous
gère pas de réponse sur qu'est-ce qui
vous a frappé qu'est-ce qui vous a
marqué au cours des dernières semaines
dans l'actualité ce n'est absolument pas
sorti même si comme Bruno cotresse l'a
très bien dit ça pourrait prendre ça
pourrait feuilletonner puisque la
question de l'utilisation de l'agent
public ou va l'argent dans un contexte
général de défiance à l'égard du
fonctionnement des services publics
l'État que fait-il de notre argent ou va
l'argent et d'ailleurs c'est une
communication parallèle du gouvernement
avec le lancement du site et de la
consultation initiée par Gabriel Attal
c'est une question qui se pose voilà où
vont mes impôts maintenant pour
l'instant ça ne prend absolument pas
alors dans la notre dernière livraison
diffusée hier soir du baromètre il faut
Fiducial pour Paris Match et SUD RADIO
symboliquement c'est Marlène Schiappa
qui connaît la chute la plus forte elle
perd 6 points de popularité est-ce qu'il
y a un lien avec le fond Marianne je ne
le pense pas je mon avis c'est plus les
controverses autour de son interview
controversé dans le magazine Playboy
c'est une idée que peut-être elle fait
jouer davantage la communication que
l'action on l'entend plus sur des
éléments de communication côté sur des
éléments du changer la vie un ministre
un responsable politique est là pour
transformer le quotidien maintenant
voilà ce n'est pas encore une affaire
d'état Christian Gravel est un grand
serviteur de l'État qui a été à la
pointe notamment sur des questions de
d'éradicalisation la présomption
d'innocence est complètement doit être
absolument respectée mais c'est vrai que
les montants peuvent si je puis dire
interloquer et comme l'a dit Bruno
cotress et un institut de sondage qui
est en lien avec la demande publique sur
des appels d'offres les choses sont
extrêmement cadrées surveillés et je le
dis les spectateurs contrôler donc voilà
pour l'instant il n'y a pas d'affaires
d'État c'est le moment qu'on puisse dire
ça ne prend pas pour le moment parce que
d'abord c'est assez récent ensuite aussi
parce que il y a déjà tout un tout un
ensemble de représentations liés à
l'activité politique et perçue quand
même de manière très négative par les
Françaises et les Français par contre
c'est vrai que si l'affaire devient un
véritable feuilleton qu'il y avait des
affaires dans les affaires c'est-à-dire
qu'on dit finalement non seulement les
principes qui ont conduit à sélectionner
des projets n'étaient pas très clair
mais en plus l'argent public n'a pas été
ensuite très bien utilisé alors ça par
contre du point de vue de l'image de la
ministre et de sa position dans le
gouvernement ça pourrait terriblement la
fragiliser on va parler des rencontres
entre les syndicats et Elisabeth borne
qui ont débuté hier elle a reçu hier
Laurent Berger et Frédéric Souillot de
force ouvrières elle va recevoir
aujourd'hui entre autres Sophie Binet la
secrétaire général de la CGT elle était
ce matin l'invité de France Inter on va
écouter ce qu'elle attend de cette
rencontre
une colère très forte dans le pays et
que c'est pas possible de passer en
force et de ne pas écouter son peuple il
faut que le gouvernement et le président
de la République reviennent à la raison
il faut renoncer à cette réforme qui ne
répond à aucune nécessité économique et
réouvrir des négociations sur la base
d'une feuille blanche ensuite je pense
que les manœuvres anti-démocratique ça
ne peut plus durer ça n'est plus
possible et qu'il serait gravissime je
dis bien gravissime que les députés
encore une fois soit empêchés de voter
sur la question de la réforme des
retraites on va revenir sur cette
histoire de PPL liotte et d'abrogation
de la réforme des retraites mais sur ce
qu'elle dit au début comment les
Français perçoivent ça se dialogue
finalement qui renouait même si on
l'entend et on entend son fibinet
évidemment ils ne sont pas d'accord les
syndicats ne veulent pas tourner la page
et les Abed bains de veut tourner la
page et il y a eu un impact de cette
réforme de retraite sur les relations
syndicales exécutives très clairement et
c'est vrai que vous l'avez bien rappelé
Oriane on est sur deux logiques
antagonistes on a un gouvernement un
couple exécutif avec aussi la très forte
occupation du terrain médiatique par
email Macron qui à tourner la page à
désaxer si je puis dire l'agenda des
Français qui était jusqu'à encore
quelques jours monothématiques à savoir
réforme des retraites j'avais été frappé
par une enquête il faut fiduciale pour
SUD RADIO après le premier mai après le
vote malgré tout de la loi par le 49-3
après la validation du Conseil
constitutionnel on avait encore 55 % des
Français qui considéraient qu'il devait
encore avoir des mouvements sociaux des
manifestations contre cette réforme des
retraits donc la logique du gouvernement
de tourner la page celle des syndicats
de continuer même si ces rencontres
constituent un élément modeste de
victoire pour le gouvernement sur le
mode business à the Joel si je puis dire
on revient au dialogue social classique
maintenant voilà faut voir ce qui va en
sortir mais c'est vrai que
malgré l'éloignement temporel des
mouvements sociaux il y a encore le
rendez-vous on va en parler du 8 juin je
suis frappé de voir que dans leur
discours les Français continuent à
évoquer la réforme des retraites continu
évoqué à soutenir le mouvement social et
ce qui est très notable et j'ai envie de
dire intéressant c'est que ils se sont
ils s'exprime moins maintenant sur le
fond ce passage tant décrié de 62 à 64
ans que sur la méthode et le 49-3 le
passage en force l'impression de
bruitalité et d'auto et d'autorité reste
toujours en pointe dans les critiques
adressées au couple exécutif et
justement sur la méthode on va parler de
ce qui va se passer le 8 juin mais sur
ce dialogue finalement qui renoué entre
les syndicats et Elisabeth borne est-ce
que ça peut déboucher sur quelque chose
Bruno cotressière Laurent Berger qui
était reçu hier soir il dit faut pas que
ça soit des mesures est
non c'est un peu vraiment ce qui est
vraiment intéressant c'est à dire qu'au
fond l'objectif du gouvernement c'est
pas seulement de ramener les syndicats
autour de la table et d'envoyer une
image une communication qui est la
restauration du dialogue social mais
c'est peut-être encore plus
fondamentalement d'amener les syndicats
presque un peu de l'or forcer le bras
pour les amener à dire qu'ils obtiennent
des choses que peut-être il n'aurait pas
obtenu s'il n'y avait pas cette
situation de tension et c'est toute
l'enjeu au fond de cette de cette mise
en place d'un renouveau de retisser le
dialogue social est-ce que les syndicats
à un moment donné vont être obligés de
dire finalement oui on a obtenu des
choses et c'est parce que la barre a été
mise très haut d'une point de vue de nos
exigences qu'on a pu obtenir des choses
et la première ministre a été obligée de
tenir compte d'un rapport de force aussi
donc voilà on voit que c'est c'est assez
subtil parce que du côté du du
gouvernement on a impérativement besoin
de gommer cette image d'un dialogue
social qui était bafoué d'un parlement
qui n'a pas été dans ses droits d'une
image de effectivement comme Frédéric
Davy vient de le rappeler d'une image
d'un pouvoir qui décide de tout toujours
tout seul donc ça c'est très important
pour Emmanuel Macron et sans doute que
du point de vue de l'exécutif on est
prêt à certain nombre de concessions
aussi pour obtenir cette image que les
syndicats a finalement sont obligés de
dire voilà on a obtenu des choses ça a
marché et si Elisabeth borne obtient ça
je pense qu'elle peut sauver sa tête oui
tout à fait d'accord c'est vraiment
l'idée de revenir à une certaine
normalité le président l'a dit dans
cette invention beaucoup de choses sur
les relations au sein de l'entreprise
sur le travail enfin l'objectif il est
extrêmement clair la finalité de tous
les messages de l'exécutif c'est désaxer
l'agenda des Français revenir à
des négociations apaisées avec les
syndicats avec un vrai direct social
sachant que clairement on l'entend quand
on entend Sophie Binet sur France Inter
tout à l'heure c'est l'idée que ça ne
passe pas du côté des syndicats
il y a une journée d'action le 6 juin
encore une fois est-ce que c'est une
logique de baroud d'honneur on l'avait
dit à plusieurs reprises ça ne s'est pas
produit est-ce qu'il y aura encore
beaucoup de monde dans la rue notamment
des salariés du secteur privé pour
espérer avec ce lapl du 8 juin que cette
réforme soit abrogée même si je suis
frappé de voir quand même que les
Français commencent commencent à tourner
la page la question sur est-ce que les
manifestations doivent se poursuivre
date il y a une quinzaine de jours il
sera intéressant de la reposer pour voir
si vraiment ça y est on va basculer sur
autre chose mais il restera toujours
j'ai envie de dire de la rancœur sur le
chagrin et c'est vrai que ça reste je
trouve l'acte lourd de cette première
année du quinquennat ce que vous ferez
vous reposerez la question mais
évidemment on va parler de cette
proposition de loi du 8 juin la
proposition de lote nouveau point de
crispation entre les syndicats et
l'exécutif hier Laurent Berger a prévenu
empêcher l'examen de ce texte serait
inacceptable on a entendu Sophie Binet
ce matin dire que ce serait gravissime
un avis que partage Charles de Courson
qui est membre du groupe piote on écoute
tout a été fait pour empêcher
l'Assemblée nationale de se prononcer
sur ce texte quel que soit l'issue du
vote du du 8 juin le but c'est de
rappeler que les seuls représentants du
peuple dans ce pays ce sont les députés
voilà qui sont les représentants du
peuple et que c'est à eux d'en trancher
quelques soit l'appréciation qu'on porte
sur l'Assemblée nationale mais voir
empêcher les représentants du peuple de
se prononcer c'est quelque chose
d'extravagant
qui était ce matin sur Europe 1 ça
serait perçu comment par les Français
une stratégie de la majorité
présidentielle qui vise à empêcher
l'examen de cette proposition quoi
n'est pas très visible et compréhensible
PPL etc mais si le message passé c'est
que de nouveau le gouvernement bloque
les choses ça sera absolument
dévastateur parce que ça pourrait
réactiver tout cet imaginaire négatif
qui a fait extrêmement de mal à la
popularité du couple exécutif madame
borne est touché par le soupçon de
passage en force d'autoritarisme de
brutalité depuis avant la réforme des
retraites depuis les premiers 49.3 de
l'automne sur le budget
2022-2023 donc ça serait je trouve de ce
point de vue là absolument dévastateur
parce que ça va encore enfermer ou
réactiver cette critique à l'égard du
pouvoir exutif en terme de brutalité
passage en force mépris des droits du
Parlement et ce serait un carburant
absolument formidable et pour la rue et
pour la scène parlementaire les des
principales oppositions notamment la
nupesse finalement la majorité
présidentielle et face à deux choix
aussi compliqués l'un que l'autre soit
empêcher l'examen de cette proposition
loi via l'article 40 qui empêche d'aller
dire la charge financière soit laisser
le texte aller jusqu'au bout avec le
risque qu'il soit voté oui c'est un
conflit effectivement très très
difficile à régler pour l'exécutif on
voit d'ailleurs que le député de Courson
si tu le débat sur la question de la
légitimité démocratique lui il dit les
seules représentants du peuple ce sont
les députés je serai plus nuancé sur
cette question les sénateurs aussi sont
des représentants du peuple de manière
indirecte mais le président de la
République élu directement par le
suffrage universel lui aussi est en
représentant du peuple on voit que sur
cette question de la légitimité
démocratique et qui porte la légitimité
démocratique c'est au fond devenu le
cœur du sujet effectivement si le
gouvernement finalement parvenait à
utiliser l'article 40 en disant on ne
peut pas débattre de cette proposition
parce qu'elle a alourdi la charge
publique
les acteurs je ne sais pas mais les
électeurs au fond n'en rentreraient pas
dans ce détail ce qui capterait surtout
ça serait à nouveau un gouvernement qui
un
c'est un aveu de faiblesse ça serait
perçu comme un aveu de faiblesse c'est à
dire de pas avoir le courage politique
ou les ressources politiques d'aller
jusqu'au bout de ce de ce vote et puis
ça serait perçu comme un coup de force à
nouveau avec une image sans doute très
difficile à reconstruire de ce point de
vue là pour Elisabeth borne qui serait
définitivement clairement pleinement on
va dire
identifier et même en calaminer dans
49,3 et passage en force et puis la
réactivation des différentes critiques
on met d'évoquer avec nos côtés se
nourrit du scénario rappelez-vous
quelques jours avant le recours au 49-3
plusieurs membres éminents mental il y a
pas de 49-3 il y aura un vote et
finalement les Français ont été surpris
du 49-3 là on est encore sur article 40
ou pas il y a un double risque aucun est
une double un double scénario aucun est
favorable au gouvernement mais je pense
que
réactiver chez les Français le sentiment
d'un passage en force serait absolument
catastrophique et pourrait le mot
détruire des définitivement l'image et
la confiance à l'égard notamment d'un
Premier ministre c'est un texte qui
pourrait passer si jamais le vote va
jusqu'au bout Bruno est-ce que c'est un
texte qui pourrait passer là encore avec
la punaise d'une partie
il semblerait au fond à nouveau reposer
sur le comportement des députés du
groupe LR
lesquels vont aller jusqu'au bout de
leur démarche c'est-à-dire ceux qui ont
pris position contre le projet du
gouvernement est-ce qu'à ce moment-là
ils ajouteraient leurs votes à ceux qui
veulent en cette proposition
l'abstention aussi ceux qui vont se
faire porter par on va dire le jour du
jour du vote donc à nouveau on va
retrouver toute une dramaturgie autour
du comportement des députés les
républicains pour les républicains et
Antoine de fond quand même quelque chose
qui devient un peu difficile pour eux
qui est calé le message que veut faire
passer souvent politique sur une
politique publique fondamentale quelque
chose de très important qui est la
question des retraites est-ce que ça va
leur lier les mains
vis-à-vis de leur agenda en particulier
de 2027 parce qu'il faudra bien un
moment donné que les républicains nous
disent s'il revenait au pouvoir quel
serait leur politique et quel serait
leur option sur la question des
retraites parce que c'est une séquence
compliquée pour la majorité
présidentielle mais aussi pour les
républicains qui n'ont jamais depuis le
début réussi à afficher une ligne claire
sur cette réforme des retraites
il y a cette tripartition du champ
politique on a vu très fortement mis en
exacte pendant cette réforme des
retraite et cette contestation le bloc
nupestre le bloc RN et le bloc central
où se trouvait l'air dans ce cadre-là et
c'est vrai que LR sort plutôt affaibli
hein toute une série d'enquêtes faites
par l'Ifop sur qui sort en français qui
sort affaibli avec une fracturation des
sympathisants de chez LR puisque dans
toutes les enquêtes on en a qui aura sur
deux qui soutient la réforme des
retraites telle qu'elle est telle
qu'elle a été votée alors même que les
réformes de structures des réformes
précédentes avaient été soutenu
massivement par LR et lrem je parlais de
Sainte Alliance LR lrem ou LR
Renaissance sur ce type de réformes
fracturation en termes de d'image dans
l'opinion entre le groupe LR du Sénat
plus classique que ce groupe LR de
l'Assemblée plus générationnelle avec
les différentes oppositions les 19
députés qui ont voté la motion de
censure oui elle est relativement
affaiblie et une fois de plus c'est
peut-être LR qui aura la clé de
la clé de la sortie de crise alors même
que la question d'une participation au
gouvernement se pose et d'ailleurs est
un parti désormais d'appoint même s'il
est très fort localement il a encore
énormément de soutien mais une fois de
plus il est dans une logique de pied du
mur sur cette question
oui de pied du mur vraiment c'est on est
vraiment un vrai on va dire une vraie
Carrefour un vrai croisement extrêmement
important pour les républicains il va
falloir qu'à un moment donné il puisse
afficher un objectif qui est un objectif
ou de participer de rejoindre la
majorité présidentielle ou de rentrer de
envoyer un message qui est d'être dans
les oppositions donc ça devient
effectivement une situation qui est très
compliquée il y a évidemment en toile de
fond à cette question
de la stratégie vis-à-vis de 2027
progressivement et en particulier sur
des dimensions économiques c'est bien
sûr des dimensions économiques on
s'attendrait normalement à ce que les
républicains se différencient de la
macronie que vont-ils dire sur la
question des déficits publics que
vont-ils dire sur l'avenir des régimes
de retraite et de ce point de vue là
c'est vrai qu'ils ont fait passer un
message qui est extrêmement extrêmement
confus sur la question des retraites
merci monsieur vous restez avec nous on
regarde ce qu'elle a une de mes
quotidien régionale
[Musique]
et si Valène de la presse régionale en
mer devant les sénateurs oui Presse
Océan qui titres sur Yannick Morez le
maire de Saint-Brévin auditionné
aujourd'hui au Sénat la commission des
lois souhaite comprendre ce qui a motivé
la décision de démissionner de ses
fonctions dans un communiqué publié la
semaine dernière il a dénoncé le manque
de soutien de l'État alors qu'il faisait
face à des pressions de riverains et de
groupuscules d'extrême droite suite à sa
décision de déménager un centre
d'accueil de réfugiés près d'une école
il sera reçu à Matignon par Elisabeth
borne ce sera en fin de journée c'est la
journée internationale de lutte contre
l'homophobie oui et la Charente Libre
fait à cette occasion un focus sur un
tabou homosexuel et croyant de choses
qui ne vont toujours pas de soi dans
l'église on retrouve le témoignage de
Gianni dans les pages du journal et à
l'occasion de cette journée de lutte
contre l'homophobie une soirée est
organisée dans une église d'Angoulême
soirée placée sous le signe de la
tolérance puisque d'autres religions
sont conviées pour l'occasion le Coran
va côtoyer la bible des prières ont
organisés et Gianni pourra témoigner
devant un parterre de fidèle la corrida
Pérol c'est non c'est non regardez Midi
Libre la justice est hier un coup
d'arrêt au retour de la corrida dans
cette ville qui est située près de
Montpellier le conseil municipal
prévoyez l'organisation mi-juillet du
novillada c'est une corrida je crois qui
oppose je garde Frédéric
oppose de jeunes taureaux à deux jeunes
toreros mais le tribunal administratif a
dit non il estime qu'aucune tradition
bien établie dans cette ville ne
permettait d'autoriser les spectacles
avec mise à mort de taureau on rappelle
qu'il existe dans la loi une
interdiction de commettre un acte de
cruauté envers un animal mais il y a une
exception lorsqu'une tradition locale
peut être invoquée en l'occurrence
c'était pas le cas
cette émission c'est notre nouvelle
plateforme public sénat.fr prochain
rendez-vous à 15h la séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement il y a 18h
Thomas Hulk sens public nous on se
retrouve lundi prochain on vous souhaite
une très bonne journée
[Musique]